the david pakman show at david
pakman.com welcome to the bonus show we
sort of jokingly said that 2016 was the
year of memes and 2017 will be the year
of memos if indeed the James Comey memos
that I guess we're going to hear more
about in detail at James Comey testimony
on Thursday end up being the blockbuster
that they might be but memes are still
important and as it turns out Harvard
University has actually rescinded the
the acceptances of ten admitted students
because of an offensive online chat that
led to a number of memes the Facebook
group was at one point called Harvard
memes for horny bourgeois teens and it
started when about a hundred members of
Harvard colleges incoming freshman class
connected contacted each other through
the university's class of twenty twenty
one Facebook group and they created a
messaging group where you could share
memes about pop culture
and I mean you're familiar with memes
right yeah you've seen me know them more
so apparently some of these memes took a
dark turn according to an article
published in the Harvard Crimson on
Sunday some of the group members decided
to form an offshoot group where you
could share r-rated means according to a
student who spoke to the Crimson and the
founders of the group chat demanded that
students post provocative memes in the
larger group to be admitted to the
smaller group I guess some kind of
initiation or hazing or whatever and it
was really really bad some of them
referencing the hanging of a Mexican
child as an activity called pinata time
others talking about being aroused by
sexually abusing children blah blah blah
blah blah university officials caught on
administration officials looked into
into this in more detail and they have
selected at least ten incoming students
and participated in the group chat who
will not be allowed to actually go to
Harvard so when I first saw this story I
saw that
invitations had been rescinded due to
social media post yes and I had just
thought you know maybe this has to do
with underage drinking or just pictures
of these kids partying right and my
sympathy went out to him because I was
thinking you know they worked so hard to
get into Harvard University and they're
going to take that away from them over
one mistake and yeah something that you
know pretty much everyone in their
adolescence does sure it's not like it's
uncommon now that you know that you know
these these memes are actually something
that's racist and you know not
advocating necessarily but you know
promoting sexual assault and joking
about joking about I think is the key
thing yeah you can't do that and when
asked about it by the Washington Post a
couple days ago Rachel Dane who's a
spokeswoman for Harvard said we do not
comment publicly on the admission status
of individual applicants so what's the
overarching thing I mean no but we might
not agree specifically about what is an
offensive enough mean to warrant having
your offer of attendance rejected or
rescinded by Harvard maybe we would
maybe we wouldn't agree but more
generally the issue is the evaluation of
someone's internet history to determine
whether they are acceptable or not to be
part of your school we know that with
employment it's widely known now that
social media history is looked at not
only LinkedIn which is more
business-related but if somebody has an
unprotected Facebook page you're a
potential employer you might look at
what that person has been posting to
Facebook to get a more general idea of
what that person mut might be like why
is it different with college admissions
right and universities have been doing
this for a while I saw something to the
effect of around 30% of colleges look
into a applicants social media presence
yes
and you'd have to imagine if 30% of
schools overall are doing it then the
most prestigious schools like Harvard
would be doing it as well no doubt about
it no doubt about it so I don't have a
problem with that insofar as it's 2017
right to pretend that the only
information that is available to
determine whether someone would be a
good or not a good fit for a job or
someone that a school wants to admit or
not admit the idea that you're limited
only to their application their SAT
scores their list of volunteering
opportunities on a 500 word essay just
completely unbelievable right obviously
there's more information available and
people are going to look for that
information they obviously have the
right to do it it is just a shame when
these students really careers and their
whole life something they've built up
yeah so much is destroyed over something
so trivial as like drinking and partying
obviously this isn't the same thing now
you'd think that in this instance you
know students who are smart enough to
get into Harvard would know better
not only to be enlightened enough not to
put up these things but just to know
that their school could look into this
stuff yeah maybe it's not the offense
that Harvard is taking to it but Harvard
is saying hey we're supposed to only
admit really smart people here and if
someone is dumb enough to post these
memes online are they really Harvard
material from an intelligence
perspective not from a morals and ethics
perspective yeah I mean maybe there's
super book-smart maybe they know
engineering or math or whatever - but
just don't understand maybe like the
social skills that you would you'd get
just knowing that you're not supposed to
put that stuff online I recently read
this book bringing down the house by Ben
Mezrich
about the mit blackjack team and
something you know Harvard MIT is not
the same as Harvard but what point that
was made in this book was that you
weren't exactly talking about a group
predisposed to have the best social
skills in terms of MIT and whether
that's a stereotype or not I don't know
but apparently it applies to some degree
to Harvard although maybe less so than
MIT I don't know I'm just fascinated
they have a blackjack team so they're
obviously they're counting cards yes
which is frowned upon but not illegal
and not illegal in the United States
although in other countries I'm not
exactly sure yeah I'll talk about that
book in more detail because I'm going to
recommend it and there's a whole
interesting subculture beat behind that
book and Ben Mezrich is writing anyway
we're getting off track some people may
have heard that we have today in
addition to my voice and Pat's voice
we're also joined great by the
construction noises which have restarted
above our heads now people who have been
with the show for a while will remember
nine months ago a year ago when we were
dealing with major construction above
our heads the old owners of our building
are no longer oh no longer owned the
building were in there's new owners and
they have decided they didn't like the
work that was done upstairs a year ago
they are now doing new work so that it's
it's all starting a new path I mean go
back to negotiating the construction
once again except with completely
different owners now oh and I love it
you know half
through a point I start losing my train
of thought and I think that the roof is
gonna cave in above me uh so far no
kayvyun no cave and it got pretty loud
last time so the structural integrity of
the building seems okay but the
soundproofing is something else okay a
couple other quick stories EpiPen
remember this controversy of months ago
about the cost of epi pens six hundred
and nine dollars for a box of two epi
pens and this led to widespread outrage
news stories stories about people who
needed epi pens and couldn't afford them
counter points being made by insurance
companies and big pharma long story
short all of that outcry over the epi
pen prices have done nothing to actually
lower the prices there's an article in
The New York Times pointing out that
nothing has really changed
even though epi pen was sort of like the
poster child for out-of-control drug
prices there's about $1 worth of
epinephrine in an epi pen and Milan the
company that sells it was selling a box
of two epi pens for six hundred and nine
dollars you had presidential candidates
talking about epi pens you had both
parties in Congress talking about epi
pens and they're going to attack Milan
for the price increase and like with so
many things in our media news cycle Pat
nothing has really changed even though
the situation with the EpiPen is
basically still the same it's because
this idea of a free-market utopia
doesn't really work when the product is
something that people need yeah because
then you're just price gouging I mean
you'd like to think that with anything
else if the price soars then there's
going to be enough negative PR to where
they're going to have to bring it down
or just to compete with other companies
right not so much when your clientele
isn't just demanding a product but
actually needing it when you talk about
the healthcare and I hate to use the
term market but when you talk about the
world of healthcare and health insurance
and pharmaceuticals you actually cannot
sensibly apply standard economic
principles to it because it is not a
normal market when you analyze
healthcare and and buy health care I
mean medical treatments and and also
pharmaceuticals and medical products
right it's all following on
under health care um if you look at
elasticity right which is a standard
concept in economics there is nothing
normal at all about what what how that
applies to the healthcare industry you
have a very weird demand situation where
until someone has a particular condition
where they need a treatment or medicine
uh there is essentially no demand for
these products and at the point at which
someone needs that because of a health
condition you have a completely
different demand curve altogether and
that's something that people just don't
understand when you talk about let's
open up healthcare to the free market
because we want the free market to
decide if the system that works best
there's nothing about healthcare that
warrants being in a free market
environment and ironically Bernie
Sanders and I think Amy Klobuchar too in
January wanted to make it so people in
United States or insurance companies
whatever could import that depends from
Canada yeah and that cost about two
hundred and ninety per unit and said
it'll crazy not less still crazy but
less exactly and you think that all the
Democrats will get behind this even some
Republicans crossed over like John
McCain and even Ted Cruz and Rand Paul
but unfortunately because of some
corporate Democrats like Cory Booker
right were unable to do it you take a
look at who Cora who finances Cory
Booker's campaigns at all times Big
Pharma so yeah it's a big messed up
system this is we talk all the time
about Republicans and Democrats are
different on many issues as a drill
starts going above my head Republicans
and Democrats are different on many
issues and on many issues they're
basically the same and when it comes to
a lot of these big business issues
they're they're very very similar
Republicans and Democrats no doubt about
it let me talk briefly about United
Airlines United Airlines has not had a
great string of public relations
recently and now orchestral violinist
Jennifer Correa is accusing a United
Airlines employee of trying to quote
wrestle away her violin as she was
trying to board a flight at Houston
George Bush Intercontinental Airport in
the United States she was actually on
our way to perform with the Missouri
Symphony Orchestra she published a
letter describing the incident written
by Houston lawyer Philip McNaughton and
she says that she was in the process of
getting on this flight from Houston to
st. Louis where she was going to perform
when a supervisor at United Airlines
refused to permit her to carry the
violin onto the plane Miss Korea
explained no I have to have it with me
what options do we have the United
supervisor reportedly told the violinist
there are no options became belligerent
when the passenger asked for the
supervisors name and then reportedly
with no provocation the supervisor
lunged for the case the violin case and
tried to physically wrestle it away from
the musician and the at that point the
passenger threatened to call security
I'm sorry the supervisor threatened to
call security and the passenger said
please call security and at that point
the United supervisor reportedly ran
away so individually this might be one
person who had no clue how to manage the
situation but it's really not looking
good for United especially with United
blaming air traffic control for flight
delays which now is at least part of the
story that's being told with Trump's
privatization of ATC okay so once you're
on the plane you're completely subjected
to United's rules you have to listen to
the flight attendants and get all of
everything that they say but the thing
is she hadn't even boarded the plane yet
right at that point I mean she's still
free enough to turn around and say well
I need my violin on me and guess I'm not
going to get on this flight right she
could have just left so at that point to
wrestle the violin away it would be
crazy listen we're talking about violin
here right not a gun to wrestle a violin
away on the plane it's not like we'd be
saying well that makes perfect sense
but your point is that on the plane you
you have to go by what the flight crew
tells you different set of rules
different set of rules you're standing
in an airport as described here and
someone is physically wrestling a
classical instrument away from you and
here's the kicker United allows small
instruments to be on their planes they
just have to be in a hard case and you
have to imagine if she's in an orchestra
she has a hard case for her violin would
imagine although I don't read that one
way or the other but you have to a suit
action he's not carrying it around in
some flimsy a cloth case of some kind
yes they allow like guitars and violins
they just have to be stored properly
even either up above or under the seat
in front of you so I mean this is just
completely wrong in all levels here do
you remember that viral video and I
don't remember if it was United or
American air
lines about a broken guitar that then
some guy whose guitar was broken made an
entire music video or something like
that about United or America having
broken his guitar and the video went
completely viral does lol to you know
but it sounds like maybe he made enough
off of that video to replace his guitar
I think you probably did yeah I think it
is awfully crowdfunding pages whenever
these things happen yeah and it's
interesting when a crowdfunding page for
a three hundred dollar item raises fifty
grand
yeah and variants it's worth it to you
apparently apparently anyway continued
bad press for United would we have heard
about this story if it wasn't for the
other things going on and United I know
what I'm saying yesterday I dragged off
of there's a high on mentality now that
people are talking about United more
people are talking about United and it
makes more headlines if it had been I
don't know Southwest would we be hearing
about it when it comes to a violin
although there's been plenty of bad
stories about stuff works as well
probably not I was given what we know
about Joe alright that's it for today
we're going to try to get the
construction construction right time for
the david pakman show at david
pakman.com
[Music]